hi my name is on mol buzzer chharia I
work in a probability and stats team at
Wolfram today I'm going to be talking
about financial time series processing
in Wolfram language I'll start with an
introduction to time series and how to
construct financial time series in
Wolfram language and then I will start
on how to process time series using the
existing functionality available in
Wolfram language for time series if I
have time I will also go through the
straighting chart and financial
indicator function in Wolfram language
the collection of order time value or
date pair date value pairs can be
represented in time series format or
event series or temporal data in time
series we assume that the observations
are in a continuous time and it only
allows one path the values between the
timestamps are interpolated by a linear
interpolation by default and during the
construction of time series we can also
specify the method of interpolation
where our while constructing time series
event series represents a series of
events in discrete time so we will not
be able to interpolate values between
timestamps sure sorry
all right
temporal data is similar to a time
series but difference is in temporal
data it allows multiple paths and
there's also one difference like when
your interpolate interpolating in
temporal data the values are going to be
hold from the left and the method of
interpolation can also be set during the
construction of temporal data today I'm
not going to talk much about event
series and temporal data but if you guys
are interested you can refer to the
documentation i'll only focus on time
series and their related functions but
the the techniques of time-series
processing can be applied to both event
series as well as temporal data here are
the list of options and properties
available for time series i'll i'll
mainly focus on resampling method and
temporal regularity options and I'll be
using all these properties throughout
the slides this is a very simple example
for constructing a time series here what
we are doing is we are we have a list of
values and we have lists of timestamps
and we we feed these two values to time
series and we can construct a time
series object in Mathematica after we
construct a time series
note that the values are ordered by time
but the thing is when we when we had a
timestamp we can see that the times time
stamps were not ordered but after
construction of time series it will
automatically or or the values are
automatically ordered according to time
this is just by design yeah but there
are multiple ways you can construct time
series but this is just a simple example
that I wanted to show here so how do we
construct financial time series right in
Mathematica or in Wolfram language we
have financial data function and we can
get a data from financial using
financial data and it returns a date
value pair so this is a different
example of constructing time series so
once we have a list of date value pairs
we can provide this date value pairs to
time series and then we can construct it
and one thing to keep in mind is like
when we are downloading a data from our
financial data function it comes in two
business days so if we use a default
setting of time series function to
construct financial time series then
when we check the regularity of the time
series it will return false this is
something that we need to figure out how
to resolve it and I will talk about this
in next few slides and this is a nice
bit list plot of our financial time
series sometimes we have to also
download the data or load the data from
file right we will be probably working
with the text file of financial data or
CSV file here I downloaded a historical
price of Starbucks from Yahoo Finance
and in order to load the data in
Mathematica we can either use semantic
import function or import function and
in this example I am using semantic
importing once we use semantic import
function it will get the data in a data
set form and we can list we can see the
first five values of first five rows of
the data set by just looking using the
part function so from dead this data set
now I am interested on constructing a
time series of a closing price so how do
I do this so I will just extract all the
data from this closed column
here and then all the data or dates from
this date column here and by using
normal function we can convert the data
that we extract it from data set into a
list and once I have the data a list of
data sets and closing price I can
construct time series by using time
series function and this is the date
list plot we can use this path length
property of time series to count how
many data are there in a path so in my
previous examples I I was just using a
default settings when I was constructing
time series and we had I mentioned about
an issue where the regularity was not
returning true by evaluating regular
sample queue so we have a temporal
regularity option in in time series
which we can set it to true in order to
make the time series regular but
sometimes when we're analyzing financial
data just assuming the regularity of a
time series might not be sufficient
enough especially when we are dealing
with a daily daily financial data so we
have to resample it occurring to the
business days because the data comes in
business days so how do we do that we
have a time series with sample function
that we can just are we can just use it
to resample it offering to the business
days so here is a simple example of how
to re sample your time series according
to business days I would also like to
introduce another function time series
window which is very handy when we want
to actually zoom in the interesting time
intervals of a time series so here is a
simple example of how to use this time
series window function in order to zoom
in the data so for instance in this in
this plot I'm just interested to look at
the data from April to July so I just
constructed this time series window
function and provided the time series
and provided the first date
the last state of the range and here's a
nice deadly spot
when constructing a time series by
default we have a linear interpolation
right sometimes it might not be the
right right behavior that we want when
we are analyzing financial time series
so let's look at this graph so when we
use a linear interpolation then what
would happen to the two the values or
when we want to find out if if the
timestamp is not inside the time times
when we want to inquire about the time
when it is not inside the time step that
that we give so for instance this a red
dot represents the first date of time
series and this blue dot represents the
last day so what's happening here is
before before the first date the values
is decreasing continuously and after the
last date it is increasing continuously
this num this might not be something
that we want when we are analyzing
multiple multiple stocks so how do we
handle this kind of situation so we can
either we can we can we can use this
function not function um we can use this
a resampling method or option when we
are constructing our time series and set
the interpolation order to zero so once
we do that what's going to happen is
it's going to actually hold the values
from the left and here we can see the
visualization of of those two
interpolation method
in Wolfram language we have functions
like log and ratios these functions can
be directly applied to our time series
and it is very useful to compute like
simple returns and log returns so here I
have downloaded I already have a time
series for Apple in Amazon and I simply
use this ratios function and log
function to compute the simple return
and log returns and this is the
visualization of Apple Apple price for
log return and as you can see from this
graph the difference between log returns
and simple returns it's not that much
but usually in finance we use log
returns for financial modeling
accumulate is another useful function in
that can be used in finance for
computing cumulative returns so if we
have a log returns then when we want to
find out the cumulative returns of an
asset then we will just be taking the we
will add the totals of accumulated
elements right so we can simply apply
this accumulate function to log returns
but I would like to mention that when we
are using accumulate function we have to
make sure this log returns are regularly
sampled
here I'm I'm commenting this core out
Butler you can use financial data
function and time series this is nice
weight of constructing a financial time
series data and it has already being
resampled so but I already have this
data over here the in time series if you
want to divide or multiply the values of
time series we can simply just multiply
or divide like other operations so here
what I'm interested in is I want to find
out the evolution of a one dollar
investment in Apple stock and then am
amazone so what I'm doing here is I'm
simply dividing the time series of Apple
and Amazon by the first value so this
first value is the property that I that
I showed in my previous slides so this
way you can actually get the first value
of your time series so I'm just dividing
it when you visualize it this is this is
the evolution of one dollar invested in
Apple and Amazon we can also we can also
divide two times one time series by
another time series so in this example
what I'm showing is what would be a
relative value of investment in Apple
compared to Amazon so if it is so one we
divided if it is going to be rather than
one it is it is it is saying that Apple
is performing better than Amazon in this
case we can also add multiple time
series at the same time and this
technique would be very useful when we
are when we are computing the portfolio
returns of multiple assets and but this
is just a very simple example of how to
arbitrarily how to add arbitrary
transferees objects
in this slide I'm showing how to use
moving map function function for for
computing the moving correlation of two
prior to two securities so here arm I
constructed a time series of two
dimension and I applied the score
correlation function to our time series
and I can I can get moving correlation
function using a moving back and since
this Apple this time series is two
dimension if I want to divide this time
series into its path component then I
can use a path component properties of
time series and I can get to different
time series so when we are doing an
analysis in fire info with financial
data you would like to figure out like
or identify the trainer like trends of
upward and downward power trains for
price movements right so how do we do
that so we have moving averages function
and time series thread function in
Mathematica or Wolfram language which we
can use combined it together and then
identify those trends so in this example
I'm computing moving averages of S&P 500
with a shorter window period and longer
window period so if the values of if the
values of shorter window period is going
to be greater than longer period then it
will signify that the price a price is
going up or upward right so so now I
will generate a signal and a buy signal
and sell signal and I will show you how
to use time series thread function to do
that so bully function basically returns
0 and 1 or 1 or 0 for true and false I'm
using this time series function I'm
defining a function to return 0 and 1
and feeding
two different time series here this is a
visualization of the signal filter that
we just generated so now what we will do
is we will use this signal filter to
generate the actual buy and sell signal
so how do we do this so in order to do
generate a buy and sell signal from that
signal filter we need to find the
successive differences between the
values across the path so we already
have a difference function in
Mathematica implemented so we simply
apply this difference function to our
signal filter and then we can gain we
can generate a time series of 1 0 and
negative 1 where 1 signifies it's a buy
signal and negative once you give
indicates that it is a sell signal so
this is a plot for them and so now I
want to find out the actual dates and of
our actual dates of upward trend and
actual dates of downward train so I can
use a cases function here and I extract
those dates and I put everything
together in a nice visualization which
shows as a price of S&P 500 two moving
averages and buy and sell signal and
this is a plot of Time series window to
zoom in to just like from here to here
here are other list of time-series
processing functions
in in Wolfram language there is we
already have implemented about like
hundred financial indicator functions
here are the list of all the indicators
that are already available with with our
language and this can be used used it
used with a trading chart in order to
visualize the candlestick chart and the
indicator function and here is a simple
example so when we are using a trading
chart we have to make sure that we are
giving you all open high/low close and
volume our volume data we can also use
financial indicator function and apply
it to a data - in order to generate the
time series this is currently not
documented yet but if you want we can
use it like this so we just have a
financial indicator function you provide
a name of the financial indicator like
it could be anything from here and then
you just apply it to a the advanced
series of data and you will get an eye
three three times to use for Bollinger
Band and you can if there is a list of
list of Time series objects then we can
use meta information property of that
time series to figure out what time
series indicates what and this is the
same graph that we can get by using date
list plot so we can do the same
visualization by using debt report
instead of my trading chart I think that
concludes my talk
thank you
[Applause]